you have to bet a certain amount to get
a certain amount you you you like the
homeboy bet y'all like at home yeah we
don't homeboy better than a casino
all right but it doesn't matter about
james harden the milwaukee bucks are
going to win tonight press the button
[Music]
wow thank you
[Music]
[Music]
this is the greatest button man you're
welcome chuck let's have a doughnut
eating contest
hey chuck hit it again that might be
something jack this is the greatest
thing in the world chris mcqueen brother
might be some milk hit it again chuck
yeah well
i think i'll start my diet tomorrow all
right my diet is shot
wow that's okay one donut don't make
ain't gonna make you overweight
it will make you
[Laughter]
it wasn't one doughnut that got him come
on come get a doughnut bro
rob come on man this thing's there there
was one donut at a time
man checking i'm sorry for you girl jack
my gosh this is the greatest thank you
very much man
nice let me give you one more take it
away though okay
yeah somebody take these away you can't
even have two
all right if i eat you before halftime i
can go home
i'll tell you what if you eat up for a
half time i'll give you the rest of the
night off
it'd be awful right after this